[Music]
well you've got your
you've got your pretty bow
chauffeur drives your car you
but don't
[Music]
st. John
by the school now
[Music]
so died
all-star
[Music]
it's nine o'clock on a Saturday
and sitting next to me making love to
his tonic
[Music]
now John at the bar is a friend of mine
he gets me
and it's quick with a joke caught a
light up your smoke but there's
someplace that he'd rather
[Music]
all is a real-estate novelist who never
had time
and he's talking with David we're still
in the name
and probably
[Music]
it's a pretty good crowd for a Saturday
and the manager gives me a smile
cuz he knows that it's me they've been
coming to see to forget about life
[Music]
ground control to Major Tom
take your protein pills and put your
helmet on
ground control to Major Tom
six commencing countdown
juseong
check ignition and may God's love deal
with you
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States Donald J Trump
[Music]
[Applause]
nice place well I've been hearing about
this one great job great job thank you
very much for being here it's an honor
and very important time in our country a
lot of things are happening and I think
when it all ends up it's going to end up
very good for everybody
it's an honor to be at Gateway Church
with the Attorney General are great
Attorney General William bar and my
friend Ben Carson has done a fantastic
job at hard secreto
and a young star Jerome Adams general
where is Jerome Jerome along with a lot
of my friends out in the audience in
fact a lot of the great political
leaders from Texas I see some great
great friends and I want to thank you
all for being here faith leaders members
of law enforcement so important we want
law and order we have to have a lot of
good things but we have to have long
over have some strength you have strike
you have to do what you have to do and
you look at a Seattle we just came in we
just see over the screen and we've been
hearing about it Bill and I were talking
about it the law and order look at what
happened in Seattle they took over a
city a city a big city Seattle the chunk
of it a big chunk can't happen that
couldn't happen here I don't think in
the state of Texas so I want to thank
pastors Robert Morris and Steve Dillon
they're great people great people with a
great reputation I have to say that
reputation and Gateway Church the team
has been incredible in hosting us and
I'd now like to ask pastor Morris and
Bishop Jackson to lead us in prayer
thank you thank you lord we need you we
need you at this time in our country and
I thank you for our president I thank
you Lord for our leaders I thank you
thank you thank you I know in the Bible
that when something was emphasized it
was repeated holy holy holy
thank you thank you thank you Lord that
we are about to bring tremendous
progress to a problem that's been here
for a long time and I thank you for this
administration and Lord we pray your
blessings your guidance today on this
meaning in Jesus name
father we thank you so much for what
you're doing today you have revealed so
many things that are untoward even evil
but we ask according to Isaiah 50 verse
4 that you would give us the tongue of
the learned that we should know how to
speak to the heart of this nation give
us a word in season to him that's weary
and waking us morning by morning God
that we would hear and speak we have a
great courageous president who's a
problem solver and let him speak as your
mouthpiece and act as your instrument
and we thank you for this time amen
I want to thank you bishop and thank you
very much pass that's great and we're
gonna be discussing some pretty
important things today I think it's all
important but the timing of this is very
appropriate this was set up actually a
long time ago but the timing is very
appropriate we are here to listen to
community and faith leaders gonna be
hearing from a lot of the good ones
some of the great ones but a lot of the
good ones and to present our vision of
advancing the cause of justice and
freedom from day one I've been fighting
for the Forgotten men and women of
America and I think we've been doing a
great job of it we've been doing a lot
in many other ways but gets lost a
little bit sometimes Bishop you know
that gets lost we've done so much a lot
of the things that we've done that we're
very proud of gets lost like we got
criminal justice reform passed and
they've been trying to do it for many
years and that
we secured permanent and record-setting
funding for HBCUs that's historically
black colleges and universities it's all
funny we created tens of thousands of
jobs with Opportunity Zones Tim Scott
and we had great senator from South
Carolina that many of you know he came
with an idea and I thought it was a
great idea and we got it done a lot of
people said that could never happen but
nobody thought it would be successful
like it has tens of thousands of jobs
and investment in communities where that
money wouldn't go and we achieve the
lowest black unemployment in the history
of our country prior to the plague
coming in from China and we'll get it
back again soon and it'll happen soon
in recent days that been vigorous
discussion about how to ensure fairness
equality and justice for all
of our people unfortunately there's some
trying to stoke division and to push an
extreme agenda which we won't go for
that will produce only more poverty more
crime more suffering this includes
radical efforts to defund dismantle and
disband the police they want to get rid
of the police forces they actually want
to get rid of it and that's what they do
and that's where they go and you know
that because at the top position there's
not going to be much leadership there's
not much leadership left instead we have
to go the opposite way we must invest
more energy and resources and police
training and recruiting and community
engagement we have to respect our police
we have to take care of our police
they're protecting this and if they're
allowed to do their job they'll do a
great job and you always have a bad
apple no matter where you go you have
bad apples and they're not too many of
them and I can tell you that not too
many of them in the police support but
we all know a lot of members of the
police I was listening today a friend of
mine his own very important person says
some of the best people he's ever met
her policemen law enforcement people and
they're taking care of people that in
many cases they never even met before
and at
danger a great risk they get shot for no
reason whatsoever other than they're
wearing blue they get knifed you saw
that the other night it was a horrible
thing but there is no opportunity
without safety in Chicago 48 people were
shot and 18 people were killed in one
day
Sunday May 31st think of that 48 people
shot 18 people killed you don't hear
about it too much every child should be
able to grow up in a safe community free
from violence and fear they've taken a
lot of the police protection away in
Chicago and they have great great police
in Chicago I know Chicago very well but
they're not allowed to do what they can
do better than anybody they could do the
job for easily Americans are good and
virtuous people we have to work together
to confront bigotry and Prejudice
wherever they appear but we'll make no
progress and heal no wounds by falsely
labeling tens of millions of decent
Americans as racist or bigots we have to
get everybody together we have to be in
the same same path I think faster if we
don't do that we have we have problems
and we'll do that and we'll do it I
think we're going to do it very easily
it'll go quickly and it'll go it'll go
very easily we have so many different
elements of strength in this country we
have such potential in this country we
have the greatest potential with the
greatest country in the world but we get
off subject we start thinking about
things that don't matter or don't matter
much and the important things we don't
even discuss but we're here to discuss
some very important things today
politicians make false charges and
they're trying to distract from their
own failed records they have some very
bad records and these are usually the
ones that cause the problems or can't
solve the problems these are the same
politicians who shipped our jobs away
and took tremendous advantage of all
Americans but African American middle
class so much of that wealth and that
money and those jobs went to China and
other countries and they get trapped
they get trapped they get trapped in a
government
they get trapped in bad government
schools so I'm gonna be announcing four
steps to build safety and opportunity
and dignity first we're aggressively
pursuing economic development in
minority communities we're doing it very
powerfully we've done it with
Opportunity Zones but we're going to go
above that at the heart of this effort
is increasing access to capital for
small businesses and that's with
minority owners in black communities and
we're going to get it done and it should
have been done a long time ago it's been
very difficult very very difficult for
some people been unfairly difficult
second we are confronting the healthcare
disparities including addressing chronic
conditions and investing substantial
sums in minority serving medical
institutions we have medical
institutions in some areas of our
country that are a disgrace I was gonna
say not up to standard they're much
worse than not up to standard they're a
disgrace take care of it third we're
working to finalize an executive order
that will encourage police departments
nationwide to meet the most current
professional standards for the use of
force including tactics for
de-escalation also will encourage pilot
programs that allow social workers to
join certain law enforcement officers so
that they work together we'll take care
of our police we'll take without the
funding police if anything we're going
the other route we're gonna make sure
that our police are well trained
perfectly trained to have the best
equipment
some of the things that we have heard
because I know a lot of the people in
the audience and they're professionals
of what they do they're successful
people and we're hearing things that are
not even thinkable I didn't even hear
I've never even heard of this before
last week it was like it started about a
week ago where I heard they want to
close up all police forces that's what
they're attacked on a very liberal
governor in the state of Washington is
we want the police force closed it's not
like they want to sort of bring a little
money into something else they wanted
actually closed and I'm thinking what
happens late at night when you make that
call to 911 a there what do you have
what do you do whether you're white
black or anybody else so there what do
you do you're dialing and there's
somebody breaking into a house and it
happens to be a violent person there are
violent people around pastor even you
will admit that right we want to think
the best but you have some very violent
people and when they're breaking into
your house at 12 o'clock in the evening
and you're sitting there and you don't
have a police force they're actually
thinking they're actually talking about
not having a police force well that's
not happening with us we're gonna have
stronger police forces because that's
what you need in Minneapolis they went
through three nights of hell and then I
was insistent on having the National
Guard go in and do their work it was
like a miracle it just everything
stopped and I'll never forget the scene
it's not supposed to be a beautiful
scene but to me it was after you watch
policemen running out of a police
precinct and it wasn't their fault they
wanted to do what they had to do but
they weren't allowed to do anything it
wasn't really their fault but they were
running down the street they weren't
allowed to do what they're trained to do
and they took over the precinct they
burned it essentially burned it down I'm
pretty good at construction I want to
tell you that was almost what we call a
complete renovation if you're lucky and
it was a very sad thing I don't think
I've ever seen anything like that I
don't think I've ever seen anything like
that but we are very proud of the fact
that I called I said I'm sorry we have
to have them
and they went in and it was like a knife
cutting butter right through aplomb I'll
never forget you saw the scene on that
road wherever it may be in the city
Minneapolis they were lined up bomb they
just walk straight and yes there was
some tear gas and probably some other
things in the crowd dispersed and they
went through by the end of that evening
and it was a short evening everything
was fine and you didn't hear too much
about that location having problems
anymore they went to other locations and
the same thing would happen as an
example Seattle would be so easy to self
would be so easy to serve we have a
governor here of a great state schooled
Texas as what other of your political
leaders including your lieutenant
governor it would solve it very easily
it's a lot of it's common sense I don't
even think it's courage I think it's
probably more courageous the other way
because I wouldn't want to be doing it
the other way it's very unsafe so I just
want to tell you that we're working on a
lot of different elements having to do
with law order safety comfort control
but we want safety we want compassion we
want everything what happened two weeks
ago was a disgrace when you see that
what happened to numerous occasions over
the last two weeks people were killed
number of people were killed and it was
very very terrible and very very unfair
number of them were police officers then
it was a very unfair situation we don't
want to see that and with strength you
wouldn't even have that they wouldn't be
in a position to do the kind of damage
that they've done they've destroyed
people they've destroyed businesses
they've destroyed African American owned
small businesses that hopefully they're
going to come back we're providing
funding for a lot of small businesses
and hopefully we'll be able to get
everybody online and get
funding to be able to open up their
stores and their small businesses again
but we're working to finalize an
executive order that will encourage
police departments nationwide to meet
the most current professional standards
of force and that means force but force
with compassion but if you're going to
have to really do a job if somebody's
really bad you're gonna have to do it
with real strength real power and I said
and people said oh I don't know if we
like that expression I said we have to
dominate the streets you can't let that
happen what happened in New York City
the damage they've done you have to
dominate the school and I was criticized
for that statement I made the safest we
have to dominate the street and they
said oh that's such a terrible thing
well guess what you know who dominated
the streets people that you don't want
to dominate the streets and look at the
damage they did so I'll stick with that
and I think most of the people in this
room maybe every person in this room
will stick with that and we're doing it
with compassion if you think about it
we're dominating the street with
compassion because we're saving lives
and we're saving businesses we're saving
families from being wiped out after
working hard for 20 and 30 years I saw
the one woman she worked 35 years
building a store and one night it was
totally wiped out it's terrible and
forth we're renewing our call when
Congress to finally enact school choice
now school choice is a big deal
because access to education is the civil
rights issue of our time and I've heard
that for the last I would say year but
it really is it's a civil rights issue
of our time when you could have children
go to a school where their parents want
them to go and it creates competition
and other schools fight harder because
all of a sudden they say while we're
losing that we have to fight our it gets
better so many different ways but there
are groups of people against it you have
unions against it you have others
against it and they're not against it
for the right reasons they're against it
for a lot of the wrong reasons and we're
going to get that straight net we've
done a lot of it we've had tremendous
success with choice we had choice in a
lot of ways we also have choice in the
military you know before I came here
the vets would wait online pastor they'd
be waiting you it wouldn't be acceptable
to you I know it wouldn't be acceptable
to the bishop I know it's gonna be
acceptable to you they'd wait for four
or five weeks to get online of that
where they were sick they were feeling
badly and they'd get online and it did
say there's a six day wait sir there's a
two week wait is a one month wait and
you'd have people online that weren't
very ill and they'd be terminally ill
before they got to see a doctor they
died and for years and years they've
been trying to get veterans choice that
means if you can't get to a doctor
reasonably quickly you go outside you go
to a local doctor around where you look
and the government pays the bill and by
the way it sounds expensive it's very
cheap by comparison it's actually much
better now most importantly we take care
of our vets by far most importantly but
but it's one of those many cases where
it's actually less costly and better
sometimes you'll see a building it costs
less money than another building that
cost more because the one that built the
one that costs war
this one looks better the one that's
cheaper it looks better they say how
much more did you spend for that
building actually we spent less you can
do that it's cold you have to know what
you're doing if you know what you're
doing that's only good for the real
estate people in here of which you're a
plenty by the way so I just want to
thank everybody this is a tremendous
place is a great city is a great great
city and with tremendous people and
tremendous pride and I say the same for
the state of Texas you know your
governor came to me and he said when you
had your bed hurricane two years ago I
gave us so much money to Texas more he
kept coming more how about so finally
you know that we took good care of Texas
is that right we took such good care of
Texas they were looking for the next
hurricane he said once an exit but they
had a big one and they say you had the
largest water dump ever it just didn't
stop it came in and you thought it was
gone and then it went back out and it
reloaded right it had happened three
times and you governor came and he
wanted to build a barrier so that water
would hit the barrier wouldn't come in
to certain parts of Texas Kobe said I
just have one more request this is after
we gave twenty eight billion dollars
twenty eight billion I mean we watch the
pennies but when it comes to Texas we
don't watch them too closely up and he
said
Governor Abbott he said just one more
request and it's a very slow one sir we
have a way of building a wall it goes up
and down it moves with the tides I said
this sounds expensive to me it was with
the tides and it's not a lot of money
could I ask you to do me one small favor
and a pro but I said how much is it sir
it's only 10 billion dollars and I said
start working on it right I said start
working on it because we can do things
to get rid of those you have some you
get hit pretty hard here they get hit
pretty hard here got there were you
affected very much when you had during
the Hurricanes itself we had a lot of
people who were displaced that came to
this area yeah well we took good care of
everybody so I just want to say this is
one of my favorite places I know we're
doing very well here during the last
process they kept saying that Texas too
close to call and friends of mine in
Texas say it's not too close to code
you're going to win in a landslide and I
said well they keep saying
we had one man got on television
actually and he said I don't know where
you come from but I don't think this is
too close to call I think he's gonna win
by a lotta we won by a lot it was 8
o'clock and the polls were closed and
they said Donald Trump has won the state
of Texas and he said it simultaneously
so and we're doing good here again but
you know one of the things I'd have to
say because this is big oil territory I
think we've done a fantastic job with
bringing back the oil in a rapid fashion
that looked pretty bad I have to look
pretty bad you had a case you had a
couple of hours where if you bought a
barrel of oil you bought it for $37 as
if they gave you 37 ok there's never
been a thing like that ever and now I
see that it's getting close to $40 a
barrel and you're back in business so we
got it done fast and we got Russia
together with Saudi Arabia and they cut
production and they got in fact fast and
we're very very proud of it
the supply changed rapidly with kovat 19
or whatever you want to call it I'd
never heard so many names you have about
30 names you can call this thing I call
it the plague from China the plague it's
not good
and it's not good and it's could have
been stopped it could have been stopped
in China but they decided not to do that
and we'll have to figure that one out
won't we
so I just want to thank everybody very
much for being here this is a very
spectacular place and I want to
introduce attorney general Barr and
secretary Carson to say a few words
along with the Surgeon General who has
been a real young star in the
administration and please if I could
Bill take over please thank you very
much thank you mister thank you Thank
You mr. president and thank you for
convening this discussion and I'd like
to thank the many impressive leaders
civic leaders religious leaders and
colleagues from law enforcement over
here that ghastly spectacle in in
Minneapolis was really jarring to the
whole nation and it forced us to
confront and think about reflect on
long-standing issues in our nation those
issues obviously relate to the
relationship between law enforcement and
the african-american community but just
to step back a little bit and take a
broader view initially I've been
thinking about how do we achieve the
full American dream for all communities
african-americans all communities and
one of the reasons I'm proud to serve in
this administration is because I think
the president is moving forward on the
on the critical elements necessary to
provide and ensure that opportunity
first and foremost economic growth
without growth there is no opportunity
second
second education I think condi rice said
a few years ago it's the civil rights
issue of our time because without a good
education we are not allowing our young
people to seize their opportunities and
pursue their dreams as the president
mentioned it's only by empowering
parents and giving them the power to
choose the education for their children
that we're ever going to be able to
obtain that third I think is moral
discipline and our young people they
have to have the discipline to seize the
opportunity to make momentary sacrifices
for later gain and traditionally that
has come and people can find it perhaps
from many sources but traditionally that
has come from religion which our
founders believes was the foundation of
our Republic
and we we have to stop policies that
undermine religion or relegate religion
out of the public square but now I get
to my job which is safety without safety
you cannot have progress you can't have
a life a decent life in a community and
you know this was struck home to me 30
years ago when I visited Trenton when I
was Attorney General last time I went to
a small barber shop in an
african-american neighborhood and there
were people there in their sixties and
seventies and they said mr. Barr we're
in our golden years and we are living
behind bars look down the street all the
bars are on our windows and the
criminals run free on the street now
we've made a lot of progress since then
the crime rate has been cut in half and
a big part of that has been improvement
in police and the progress we've made in
policing and yes the progress that
police have made police departments have
made in building relationships with a
community I think law enforcement has
understood for a long time that there is
distrust in the african-american
community toward the law enforcement
system and when you reflect on our
history you could understand why because
for most of our history just up until
the last 60 years the institutions in
this country the laws and the
institutions were explicitly
discriminatory there was not equal
protection of the law by law and it's
only been since Jim Crow that our laws
have been changed to provide for equal
justice and what we've had really since
then and so the civil rights effort up
until that time was to tear down
institutions but I don't think now is
the time to be tearing down our
institutions because we've been on a
March for the last 50 years of reforming
our institutions we don't need to tear
them down we have to be mature about
this and when we see problems we have to
redouble our efforts to reform
our institutions and make sure they're
in sync with our values and I don't
think anyone who's honest would deny
that we've made a lot of progress in
policing over the last 50 years and in
fact you know one of the things about
this episode in Minneapolis was how fast
both the state and federal law
enforcement responded to to dealing with
with that action so I think that while
we saw something very bad it has helped
perhaps galvanize the will of the
country to bring good out of that and we
can't let that incident obscure the fact
that progress has been made that
policemen are by and large by
overwhelming majority good decent people
who care about their community and put
their lives on the line for us their
neighbors
and we can't lose sight of the fact and
can't let this event obscure the fact
that the the real oppression and danger
to our communities comes more from
violent crime and lawlessness than it
does from the police now we've never
we've never had a we've never had a
president who was more committed to
reforming law enforcement and he's done
that with the first step back and with
the first Police Commission since Lyndon
Johnson and I'm very optimistic about
you know what we're gonna be able to do
given his leadership but also given the
leadership of our police forces which
around the country increasingly have
become better and better lead and that I
think the police profession is itself
committed to addressing the issues that
we saw in Minneapolis and completing the
process of professionalizing policing in
this country and as the president said
we're working on a number of things
through the commission that he set up
and also through an executive order to
propel that process even faster by
looking at how we can encourage the
adoption of of guidelines about the the
use of force that are acceptable both to
the community and to the and to the
police profession but also to encourage
certification of police forces and also
through such activities as increasing
grants to encourage the use of Ko
responders more and more our police are
being asked to deal with problems that
that you know hasn't previously been the
problem of law enforcement they have to
deal with homeless people they have to
deal with a lot of mental health issues
they have to deal with drug addiction
the the drug addicts and so forth and
providing some additional support that
the police in these areas is going to be
important so let me just say that the
Department of Justice is committed to
support the president's effort
here do all we can to bring good out of
this bad incident thank you thank you
surgeongeneral well Thank You mr.
president thank you everyone for coming
today thank you to the panelists I just
want to start off by saying that many
people across the country and across the
great state of Texas are hurting right
now due to the tragedy that occurred to
George Floyd and I just want to extend
my condolences to the Floyd family into
the entire Texas community because I
know that you all live together you work
together you play together and you hurt
together here in Texas and so I want you
to know that I feel that for you the
president asked me to give you a quick
update on America's Kovan 19 response
thanks to cooperation with state and
local partners we're making progress
against the virus we are and towards a
safe reopening through strong public and
private partnerships America has now
done more than 20 million tests and that
number is a big number it's not just
about the number it's also about how
many of those tests are coming back
positive and we have a positive rate
under six percent nationally and from a
public health perspective if we're under
10 percent positive we're doing a good
job so there's a lot of challenges out
there but I want you all to know that we
are moving in the right direction that
data shows that we are moving in the
right direction as a nation and this has
happened in part thanks to opening of
over 500 community-based testing sites
through the work of private sector
partners in the United States Public
Health Service which I helped lead with
Admiral Joe wah
70% of those sites are in CDC designated
vulnerable areas that means that we're
taking the testing to those who need it
the most to those who are most at risk
we also have testing it 92% of America's
community health centers which
predominantly serve low-income areas and
communities of color
we've helped equip our frontline workers
our health care heroes with 94 million
in 95 respirators 149 million surgical
masks and more than a billion gloves and
a large proportion of those supplies
that the president and the Secretary of
direction are going to nursing homes and
I just want to icy the governor over
there I want to give you all a shout out
Texas has led the way in nursing home
testing a hundred percent of their
nursing homes have been tested they're
leading the way and testing people in
Corrections facilities over ninety five
percent of people in Corrections
facilities facilities have been tested
that is something you all should be
tremendously proud and these efforts
have allowed States to proceed with a
safe reopening while we work with states
to monitor the incoming data we know
we're gonna have clusters while we
respond to spikes and we adjust policies
as needed but I want you to know that
safe reopening is crucial for other
areas in health - we need Americans to
be able to return to cancer screenings
my wife just finished cancer treatment
if she'd had to wait six months to get
her cancer screen she might not be here
today we need people to get their
surgeries we need people to get their
vaccinations 4.2 million children are
behind on vaccinations now because of
the Cova closures we know every 1%
increase in unemployment equates to a
1.3 percent increase in suicides 1.3
percent increase in suicides so we want
to reopen safely we also have to
remember that being shut down has health
consequences beyond kovin we know that
being out of school is bad for your
health we need to get our kids back in
school safely
I have a 15 a 14 and a ten-year-old and
so can you tell I've been saying that a
lot but we know that covin 19 has a
tragically disproportionate burden on
communities of color black Americans
hospitalized at 4.5 times higher rates
than whites hospitalization rates 3.5
times higher for Hispanics and whites
and 5 times higher for American Indians
and Alaskan Natives the fact that this
virus is exploiting and exacerbating
pre-existing health disparities and
these disparate outcomes and
opportunities for health are in part the
anger the frustration and the fear that
we're seeing manifest in protests around
the country and that's why it's
important for people to know that beyond
talking about the problem at the
president's direction at secretary
adores direction HHS and the White House
opportunity and revitalization Council
are wark are focusing resources on
minority communities HHS recently
allocated 15 billion dollars to Medicaid
providers and 10 billion to safety net
hospitals both groups of providers that
disproportionately serve Americans of
color and I spent the last 10 years
working at a safety net hospital
Eskenazi hospital in Indianapolis I can
tell you those are the places that are
doing the work those are the places that
at the president's Direction were we're
focusing our resources towards we're
working with a consortium with the
consortium of black medical schools to
fund in scale local efforts in
communities that again reach communities
of color CDC now requires all testing
data reported by States include
information on race ethnicity and zip
codes so we can continue to further
refine and focus our strategy on the
hardest hit communities CMS is
deregulating telemedicine to make
ongoing care for many medical conditions
safe accessible and convenient for the
patients and for healthcare
professionals again we can't afford to
let people continue to go without their
care and the administration's emphasis
on public-private partnerships is
allowing us to progress towards a
vaccine and treatments at a record pace
as a part of Operation work speed I want
to add that SAMHSA's just funded three
community behavioral health clinics
right here in Texas
the cure of that funding some of your
congressional representatives are here I
want to say thank you to you all for
passing that in to the president for
sign in to address Kovac 19 and
behavioral health needs these facilities
integrate mental health substance abuse
treatment and physical health care in
one setting and provide 24/7 crisis
intervention services another notable
mental health awareness training grant
is in Austin where funds are used to
Train community health officials
including law enforcement and we have
many of them in the crowd today on
recognizing signs and symptoms of mental
illness and mental health crises and how
to help an individual who's struggling
that's all part of reform that's all
part of reform and the positive
direction giving our frontline workers
the tools and the training they need to
be able to take care of these difficult
situations as mayor service the Turner
said at George fleurs funeral we must
encourage business leaders to invest in
our underserved communities and that's
what the White House Opportunity
revitalization Council is all about I
have upcoming surgeon general's report
on community health and economic
prosperity which aims to mobilize
businesses to invest deeply in overtime
in the health of their communities
finally to focus on chronic conditions
that disproportionately impact black and
brown people and may worsen because of
koban secretary ather have instructed my
office to accelerate the release of two
calls to action the first on maternal
health addressing the fact that women of
color suffer more complications in a
much higher risk of dying around
childbirth black women are four to five
times more likely to die around
childbirth than white women the Native
American women are more likely to die
around childbirth
then then white women and that's after
you control for income after you control
for education after you control for
every known factor that we that we had
my second call to actions on
hypertension control for all Americans
hypertension is common it's costly and
it's treatable and yet control rates are
low installed especially in communities
of color so I just want to close by
saying that as we reopen the basic
public health recommendations we've
emphasized remain important we've
flattened occurs but that doesn't mean
that kovat has gone away that if any
less contagious that it's any less
deadly to vulnerable communities so if
you don't want
listen to me listen to Hall of Fame
pitcher Nolan Ryan Nolan Ryan filmed a
PSA at the governor's direction and he
said number one wash your hands wash
them more than you've ever washed them
before in your life
number two follow your local and state
guidelines around social distancing this
virus likes to spread person-to-person
so the more we can keep distance between
people especially people we don't know
the harder it is for this virus to
transmit and number three is it may
speak and this is Nolan Ryan Hall of
Fame pitcher here when you're at a
public place where it's difficult to
keep a distance like the grocery or
pharmacy the CDC recommends wearing a
face covering to protect your neighbours
in the event that you have kovat and you
don't know it up to 50 percent of people
who have kovat are asymptomatic so
thanks to the hard work of so many
healthcare and public health
professionals and that commitment of the
American people I want to reiterate
because you don't hear this enough that
we are making huge progress in the fight
against kovin 19 and as a member of the
task force I can tell you that we
frequently talk about the great work
Texas has been doing up until this point
to keep the people of Texas safe to keep
the most vulnerable members of their
community safe and with every American's
help with your help Texas will keep
making progress we're going to beat this
virus and thank you for the opportunity
mr. president thank you thank you very
much
ben Carson please okay well thank you
mr. president for your leadership and
your courage I don't know of anybody who
could stand up to all the criticism you
get every day you know our nation is
continuing to a path of renewal or
recovery from the corona virus pandemic
but since the beginning president has
talked about being a champion for the
Forgotten men and women of this nation
that's exactly where we've been
concentrating and it's been an honor to
serve in an administration with that
goal and I'm excited to see America
beginning to bounce back the
infrastructure the economic
infrastructure of our country is very
strong secondary to the abolition of
multitudinous regulations and targeted
tax cuts it's still there that
foundation is there and we will be able
to get back on that track pretty quickly
but to help speed this rebound the White
House opportunity and revitalization
Council was formed to really help the
long-forgotten communities achieve
Economic Opportunity and it has been
refocused at your direction to help
America's hardest hit communities
achieve economic recovery overcome
health disparities and thrive through
educational and workforce advancement
now to stimulate economic development
and entrepreneurship the council has
worked to set aside additional payment
protection funding for our nation's
low-income minority communities and
provided technical support to help these
communities to access this funding they
have stated that during the first round
the money wasn't getting to them we are
addressing that and I want to thank all
the different agencies virtually every
government of age
see has contributed significantly to
refocusing and addressing these problems
the groundbreaking initiative known as
Opportunity Zones which encourages
long-term investment in the Forgotten
communities will also be expanded to
include more of the underserved areas
another major initiative improving
health and public safety comes with
several administrative and legislative
proposals for example we believe both
telemedicine and increase use of mobile
care can be major catalyst and our
mission to overcome health disparities
and underserved communities those are
things that can actually be done very
rapidly to bring healthcare to people
who've previously been neglected and to
further this effort we're also committed
to reforming the infrastructure of our
public health data system addressing
chronic conditions and interest
populations and working to address food
insecurity and underserved communities
that means healthy foods at reasonable
crisis that are accessible but one of
the things that I just mentioned the
data collection we have 50 states and
and we have territories in Washington DC
and we have all of those many different
healthcare collection systems and we are
working to homogenize all of that will
make it much easier for us to identify
quickly health issues and to be able to
address them very quickly other
legislative proposals such as advancing
national broadband access and investment
and minority serving medical
institutions will also play a major role
in improving the well-being of these
forgotten communities making sure that
we have broadband access will give
access to remote learning we will have
the possibility of taking a very best
biology
and instead of put him in front of 30
students putting in front of a million
students so that those students who've
been neglected during all this time and
relegated to places where they're not
getting an appropriate education will be
able to access those things but to
guarantee that fruits of these efforts
and that they're long-lasting we
understand the need to go forward with a
long term view through our focus on
education and workforce development
education and workforce development is
what leads to real independence for
people and the council supports
empowering disadvantaged students with
dual enrollment opportunities the
creation of new short-term education and
career pathways and increase access to
capital for our nation's HBCUs school
choice measures presidential
scholarships and second-chance Pell
grants to reintegrate formerly
incarcerated individuals our initiatives
that will prove valuable investments in
our country's human capital and we must
remember these innovative new approaches
and education and workforce development
are nothing less than an investment in
our future
we only have three hundred and thirty
million people in this country sounds
like a lot of people but compared to
China it's a quarter of what they have
India it's a quarter of what they have
and we have to compete with them in the
future so we need to develop all of our
people and you know education in
particular played a big role in my
development I was not a particularly
good student and that's putting it
mildly everybody thought I was stupid
except my mother she was always saying
Benjamin you can bring home much better
grades than this but I would agree that
I could but I did but interesting ly
enough you know my mother studied the
homes of the that she cleaned as a
domestic she came from nothing
twenty four children got married when
she was 13 dire poverty discovered her
husband was a bigamist but she was still
smart enough to study those people who
had these beautiful homes and she
figured that the reason they did so well
because they were well-educated and they
read a lot and they didn't watch a lot
of TV so she came home and imposed that
on me and my brother and we were not
happy campers let me to where today's
world we would have caused social
services and they take them but but what
a difference it made you know starting
to focus on education starting to read
books to read about people from lots of
different backgrounds entrepreneurs and
scientists and explorers and surgeons
and I begin to recognize that the person
who has the most to do it what happens
to you is you it's not somebody else
and nobody can stop you once you decide
and that's why with the console there is
so much emphasis on education because it
doesn't matter where you came from you
get a good education and you write your
own ticket and we must reject those
people who are trying to prevent school
choice who are trying to prevent the
presidential scholarships all the things
that are there to empower people and
when you will see a lot of that coming
out of this administration and you know
these investments and innovation
give me a tremendous amount of hope for
the future of this nation mr. president
under your leadership I'm confident that
the American people will emerge stronger
from this pandemic and more determined
than ever and we the people will
recognize despite all the forces to the
contrary that we are not each other's
enemies
that's great Thank You Ben
that was pretty good standing O for Ben
yeah
he's used to that easiest soon great job
Center fantastic job at HUD I have to
tell you that how about Scott will go
quick Scott so we get to we'll get
something but Scott Turner is he's a
star he's a young star go ahead Scott
well Thank You mr. president and thank
you for your leadership and giving me
the opportunity to Shepherd the White
House opportunity and revitalization
Council and it's also been a great joy
to work on a daily basis with dr. and
secretary ben Carson and so dr. Carson
thank you for your leadership and your
trust and confidence in me I just want
to deliver some good news along with dr.
Carson everyone on the panel you know
oftentimes you don't hear about the work
of Opportunity Zones but the tax cuts
and Jobs Act that the President signed
into law in 2017 created the opportunity
zone initiative and the president
created the opportunity zone Council and
that council was made up to take 18
agencies 15 federal and three state and
regional partners and move in a singular
motion to direct resources into our most
distressed vulnerable forgotten
communities and with this and that is
it's a tremendous time and so our
agencies on the council direct is a
resource we found 270 action items to go
directly into distressed communities to
help the vulnerable people of America
and we've built tremendous coalition's
partnerships on the ground we've been to
over 60 cities I've been to every one of
them over the last year to visit people
on the ground education leaders faith
leaders community leaders business
leaders elected officials Democrat and
Republican see to think about poverty it
doesn't care what party you are the
thing about revitalization it doesn't
care what party you are we're coming
together as a people for the good of the
community and
times you may not hear about this but we
sit at convene and such as this with all
of these stakeholders at one table to
have the hard conversations what is the
pain of the community why is the
community distress and what can we do
together both black and white Democrat
and Republican come together for the
good of this community for long term
sustainability for generation or impact
and because of that because of these
partnerships because of this
collaboration together and many people
all at this table have been working
together to bring about generational
impact so long after we're gone and
history tells the story there
Opportunity Zones is more than just a
program it's more than just a concept it
is a mission that is to outlast all of
us and I tell you that as you're here
because a lot of times people see a
government program and sister check the
box this is not a government program
this is built from the grassroots from
the bottom up to affect the people in
America mr. president I would say tens
of billions of dollars have been
invested inside of Opportunity Zones
public-private partnerships Erie
Pennsylvania st. Louis Missouri West
Dallas right here in my great home state
of Texas and other across the nation
much money coming in to our distressed
communities and I say all that to say
even though you don't hear about it
often we have put our hand to the plow
and our feet to the ground and all of
these things were done prior to Kovac
but I want you to know that right now
and post Kovac that our spirit remains
the same that our heart is set our face
is set like flint our mission is not
done but we're going to need all of you
to pray for us to walk with us to
convene with us to invest to teach and
so mr. president thank you dr. Carson
thank you and to all of my colleagues at
the table thank you for your support
it's been a great honor thank you very
much
thank you great
well Thank You mr. president I just was
thinking about that 30 years ago I was
serving as an associate pastor at a
small church and I asked Bishop Harry
Jackson to come and teach us on race
relations to teach us what we didn't
know because we don't know what we don't
know and now 30 years later Bishop Perry
in our setting on each side of the
President of the United States was
concerned about healing a problem that
we've had in our nation for a long time
but not just addressing one part of the
problem but housing where the Secretary
of Housing education justice here
Attorney General bar thank you for being
here thank you a great governor governor
Abbott and I believe that we're going to
work together
and we're going to see freedom and
justice for all
in America thank you thank you mr.
president
thank you pastor Morris for off from
your church I think right now like any
other time in our nation's history we
need God
[Applause]
I'm praying to the Holy Spirit to put
words on my mouth right now
and I want a nation to hear me
we need the fear of God mr. president
you're the only Republican I've ever
voted for
[Applause]
and I don't just say that to make you
feel good honesty that's not my goal man
I'm saying that because you stood up for
the Word of God and as believers as the
church we have to pray for our president
and have his back when you raised that
Bible up after those folks burnt that
church we are in a spiritual warfare we
cannot fight this battle with flesh and
blood we cannot fight this battle with
politics
you cannot politicize oppression I grew
up right down the street I looked at
skinheads in the eye at 13 years old my
black father went to a KKK rally to
protect me I know what racism is so when
I hear words get thrown out about white
supremacy it eats me up because these
being our white supremacy
that's not what they look like I'm
telling them black kids across America
right now we always hear we don't have
black leaders look at this table
we are not as divided as our politics
suggest we are not as divided as our
politics suggested but I tell you what
this president when I walk into my
prisons I'm blessed I teach in prisons
across our nation
men who are broken the most broken men
in our country our Bible teaches us to
serve they're what those in prison our
Bible teaches us to serve the poor and
when I walk into my class and I say guys
raise your hand if you've gotten your
sentence reduced from the first step act
and every single one of them raise their
hand you mr. president and that's
because of policy but you're brave
enough to go against what everyone else
has said about you now I'm calling you
to do more we have a real issue in our
country in the root of it let's not get
our eye off the enemy the root of it is
fatherlessness our kids don't have
fathers attorney
AG boy you said it earlier you talked
about pulling God out do we talk about
education
well 71% of those kids that drop out of
high school don't have a father in the
house we talk about criminal justice
reform you're five times more likely to
go to prison or have a run-in with the
police department if you don't have a
father in the house we talk about health
care you're four times more likely to
live in poverty if you don't have a
father in the house which means you're
going to be sicker we don't have to keep
looking for the problem when we see it
now it's time for Americans of all color
I'm calling on my white brothers and
sisters I'm calling my my spanish
brothers and sisters get out of your
bubbles go into the communities that are
underserved and let's do what Jesus told
us to do
we can bridge this gap of fatherlessness
all we gotta do is go out of our bubbles
don't bridge the gap with these kids
teach them what you teach your kids we
all have rooms in our homes for a couple
couple little boys to come in and play
with our sons and daughters
let's bridge the gap through love
through Christ and through being what we
all know we are and that's one America
god bless america
anybody like to speak please who goes
after that mr. president I'd like to
speak my name is will Douglas I'm the
owner thank you the owner of crimson
care pharmacy group here in Dallas Texas
and I'm also a Republican nominee for
state representative here in Texas yeah
first of all I just want to thank your
administration as well as Congress for
getting the PPP loans I'm speaking on
behalf of my pharmacies as well as a
dozen or so other pharmacies here in the
state of Texas that benefited from those
because of the PPP loans I was able to
not have to let any of my employees go
and in fact I was able to hire
additional employees because our
business model had changed overnight no
longer could customers come into our
store they were having to go through the
drive-through
which created a whole litany of other of
other issues so so for that thank you
the reason why or the reason why I'm
running for office is because to me
capitalism is the most important thing
capitalism has created this bastion of
free-market enterprise that we have here
in Texas with Dallas being the crown
jewel and I'm afraid that we're going to
lose that system that lifts people out
of property I was on a call with with
leaders in the black community here in
Dallas the other day and one of them
said something to me that that it stuck
out heard that did stuck out and and I
can't let it go and that's that I think
he said it was an African proverb but
that a child that is not embraced by the
village will burn that village down just
to fill its morals as Republicans we
have to find ways to make capitalism
embrace the people that it's left behind
because if we don't the next time it
won't just be villages and businesses
that are being burned down it will be
this system that has lifted so many
people out of poverty
so mr. president I'll be I'll be short I
just was going to say that thank you so
much for your leadership and I think
that infrastructure that you presented
today um is gonna help a lot of people
it's gonna touch businesses like William
is gonna keep community safe with the
partnership of these law enforcement
officials in the partnership with these
ministers that we have and advocates
like John ponder and Jack Brewer and so
over the next couple of weeks I think
the American people look forward to
seeing the wealth of executive orders
that you're going to issue on justice
and on economic empowerment as well as
legislative ask that we're going to make
to the hill but we all need your help on
every locality every group or
organization because it's really about
bringing us all together together that's
the secret ingredient and it has to
start at the local level it starts at
the local level because you are closer
to the people and we want to create that
infrastructure and give you the tools to
help you do what you do best and that's
helped people prosper so thanks again
mr. president I'd like to say thank you
for putting this together putting this
together in our state of Texas right
here in Dallas a lot has happened in the
last week I'm one of your officers here
in Dallas I'm also one of your
commissioners on your law enforcement
administration with a attorney general
bar I can't thank you but I also have to
say thank you to our great governor and
our leadership that's sitting right
there without them if you don't make
this state
like the state great we've had some
challenges because of what's happened
with Kovac but I want to give you an
update of what we've done on the
Commission so far where we've had nine
full hearings throughout this entire
time
that's 35 panels 125 witnesses 190
written statements that from individuals
and interest groups are civil rights and
community engagement organizations that
we've asked to attend have no-showed and
those are the ones who can make the
biggest difference when you're putting
together any type of reform because they
need to be the voice to come tell us
what we need
law enforcement today is not what it was
yesterday in my 25 years we've watched
it propelled to where our training is
what we need the most and with this bill
you're gonna see or with this commission
you're gonna see so many growth reforms
come out of it it could not have come at
a better time we can't take back what
happened in Minnesota not one officer
that saw that or federal officer and saw
that said that was the right thing that
happened that was that was it was it was
mounds and none of us we can condemn it
if I could have trade places with mr.
Floyd I would because I would die for
every one in this room because that's
our job and any one of those officers
were there I would have done that too
because I wouldn't have let that happen
and I have to say this to the citizens
that we serve in the citizens that are
listening we see you we hear you we are
with you and we're gonna make this
better
mr. president I just want to thank you
for your leadership echoing sentiments
of some of my colleagues up here today
thank you for your stance on criminal
justice reform thank you for not
forgetting about the Forgotten people
thank you for your commitment and your
support to the men and women of law
enforcement in this country and his soul
so very important my name is John ponder
I'm the CEO of many called hope for
prisoners and what hope for prisons does
is we work with men women and young
adults that are exiting different arenas
of our judicial system to provide the
supportive services to help them to be
able to successfully reintegrate back
and get at home back into the workplace
and ultimately back into the community
and mr. president thank you for coming
out and attending the graduation
ceremony for those 31 men and women who
were released from prison I cannot tell
you the the wind that was beneath their
wings because you came and spoke life
into them and they're on the whole new
list of life right now because of that
one of the huge components this is why
I'm so supportive of your stance of law
enforcement because one of the key
components to this reentry mechanism
that we built up is our partnership with
the police our local sheriff in Las
Vegas Nevada has given us close to a
hundred volunteer police officers that
are mentoring and training men and women
coming home from the prison system and
so never before in the history entry
with nowhere on this planet to this
magnitude had the men and women from law
enforcement come alongside formerly
incarcerated folks and helped them to
successfully reintegrate back into the
community that is just further evidence
that we serve a gigantic god that wants
to breathe
five that is so important because what
God wants to do the Bible calls it the
repairer of the breach seeing
communities across our country there's
such a disconnect between law
enforcement and people from this second
limited population but when we're able
to come up with with very creative ways
to bring folks together because you
think about it all across the country
that then that disconnect people do not
trust police do you know why because
they're not in relationship with them
and in what relationship could you ever
have trust unless his life rubbing up
against life in the spirit of complete
transparency that we have more in common
than we have differences and out of that
transparency build the relationship and
out of that relationship it gets
established trust it is something that
second chance employers have absolutely
fall in love with when you can tell you
know tell the employer that the the the
the person that's coming that just came
home from prison that it the mentor is a
captain of the Las Vegas metropolitan
Police Department that begins to just
open doors so I thank you for that
looking so very forward to you know the
direction that we're going and on behalf
of the men and women who are
incarcerated right now and our prison
system across the country thank you for
creating that atmosphere for them on the
inside but I know that you have dug the
trenches to create an atmosphere for
them once they get release so I thank
you
great job yes Thank You mr. president
for putting this together today I've
learned so much from these men and women
on this stage I really appreciate that
thank you for you know my name is dr.
Robin Armstrong and I I'm a physician
and I've had an opportunity to treat
many many patients with with the plague
from China and and it's been and with
the Cova 19 and so we've had a lot of
opportunity barriers in the FDA to allow
us to to to use medications like
hydroxychloroquine and and skews
medications like grim death severe and
plasma infusions and all those
medications that are coming online now
thank you so much for that you know it's
been I have the opportunity to we had a
nursing home in South Texas that that
had an outbreak of Cobra 19 and we saw a
lot of nursing facilities around the
country that we're having horrible
outcomes and many deaths and and what we
decided to do was was commit to to this
facility and use the medication that you
are familiar with eyedrops II
chloroquine and we saw tremendous
outcomes and and it was of some of our
elected officials our lieutenant
governor and a state senator we were
able to get access to those medications
but one of the more frustrating things
I've seen has been the resistance of
some of the regulatory agencies to be
more open to using that I believe that I
certainly know that that Cova 19 has has
significantly adversely affected the
african-american community and and I
really believe that had there been more
of an openness by by the regulatory
agencies certainly by by our medical
boards all around the country to use
medications like eye drugs at work when
I believe more lives could have been
saved and so I really I want to thank
you for
for bringing that issue to the forefront
because I believe that it it did give us
more access to medications and so in it
so was helpful for us I believe it saved
lives I believe we could have saved more
lives but but I just want to thank you
for the work has been done where you
know regulations and you've really broke
down a lot of barriers and regulations
and in the business community certainly
I would appreciate your what you've done
on attempting to to repeal Obamacare and
all the efforts you've made towards that
that that's certainly going to improve
access to care and so I just want to
thank you for all you've done but we
need to do a lot of work going forward
to make sure that we minister to those
who are most vulnerable and so we really
appreciate that thank you for all the
work that that that secretary Carson is
done and secretary ASR is done and and
our Surgeon General here is done thank
you for for allowing them to have the
freedom to be able to innovate and do
things and and and and look at the data
and make decisions and so we really
appreciate that and thank you so much
and physicians are very supportive of
you we're really supportive of
everything you've done to help bring
this very inexpensive treatment to the
forefront and so thank you very much
thank you very much
please mr. president thank you for this
opportunity I'm humbled to be here
I'm chief Dooley Glen Heights Police
Department my experience is based on
serving in a large department in a small
department and I can tell you that there
is some phenomenal police work being
done out here across the board across
the board but there's also some
inconsistencies in our procedures our
policies our hiring practices our
termination practices our disciplinary
practices and I strongly support the
need for standardization based on best
practices for all police departments in
our country I thank the president for
his foresight for making these things
come to happen I know they're coming and
we need it we are a country of very good
departments but we need to be a country
of great departments and this message
today is about the transition to
greatness we have an opportunity in this
country to transform the future of law
enforcement but we need to make sure
that we have a relentless pursuit of
dedication to public service at all
times and at all levels
specifically national consistence policy
on use of force every chief would be in
support of that mandatory participation
and natural a national use for database
use the force database yes it needs to
happen
development of net natural national
statements for discipline and
termination of police officers that
needs to happen development of a public
a police officer decertification
database yes we need to be able to get
those bad apples out of our industry
so we need to enhance the police
leadership in a culture and it starts at
the top we have some great leaders in
this country but we can always be better
we can always continuously improve we
need to implement improved recruitment
hiring and promotion practices that are
dedicated to having officers that are
relating lately pursuing the service of
not the community but our community it's
about no not dividing us
but uniting us and understand that we
come from the community we need to
enhance the ability for police agencies
to implement effective discipline we
need to make sure that we have policies
that establish a framework for a
community policemen engagement that
fully embraces that police officers
serve protect and connect everyone in
our community so that we all can become
better we need training this is not the
time to defund police departments in an
organization or a business is struggling
to be better now is not the time to take
away those resources you provide them
and you hold them accountable and you
set expectations and you and you manage
them so they can be better that's what
you do
we need more training we need more
specific training that's dedicated to
service of those that every one we enact
with on a daily basis those that are
homeless those that suffer from mental
illness those itself that need food okay
we need the training to be able to
connect those people we interact with
with those that can provide those
services that's what we need in this
country I want to end with
just these few thoughts I have a very
simple saying to my officers that we
serve protect and connect and together
is better and as I look around this room
I know that together we will become
better and we will take this country to
great levels under the leadership of
Donald Trump
thank you very much beautiful so it's
time to say goodbye we'll be back we'll
be back and I just want to thank Bishop
you've been my friend for a long time
and I appreciate everything you've done
and everything you've said a great
unifying source of strength and
everything else and I appreciate it very
much and you can add one last wish
please I'm tired of people blaming the
current administration and others in our
generation these problems began many
years ago and what he's been exciting to
me is was the church that began the
abolitionist movement it was the church
and whites and blacks working together
that started the NAACP it didn't have a
black leader at the beginning at the
time it was the church that led through
in the civil rights movement so I want
to offer you my support in these
listening sessions in that the church
needs to come together I believe we can
unify better than any group and what
we're looking for you to do is to give
structural guidance which you're working
on in your you've already brought forth
some amazing things but I want to affirm
that Democrats can't kneel down and
where can take off and stop black pain
Republicans can't take some one-time act
and stop that black pain but I believe
we've got a man here who's courageous
enough to begin something that's tough
and that we're going to this time heal
and so I weep over this I pray for you
as you know and we believe we're going
to get it right okay to say one last
thing being a I lost my late wife a
couple years ago I found out in dealing
with her that sometimes you just gotta
listen feel her
if you try to fix it too early you're
gonna make a mistake your listening
sessions or wise because it's going to
give that cathartic process a chance so
I don't want to take up too much time
sir but I wanted to say that the people
here I challenge you Christians black
white asian let's come together and
let's provide a safety net and then
we'll work with business and then we'll
work along with the administration but
don't push them out here up front and
say kitchen outputs and outputs analysis
now because there's never worked that
way thank you sir thank you very much
thank you everybody
thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
the killing of George Floyd and
subsequent protests against police
brutality have changed the way a lot of
people are listening to music podcasts
reading watching movies and TV shows no
media outlets have been sharing
different lists and books you can read
to be an anti-racist or to learn about
the history of race relations
hi it's Lukas Shaw and I'm an
entertainment reporter for Bloomberg in
Los Angeles streams of songs like this
is America by